the upcoming Mass Effect Andromeda has
lost one of its senior members of staff
I'm Dave and welcome to your renegade
aligned GS news update lead writer chris
live confirmed on Twitter today that is
left Bioware to join destiny developer
Bungie according to his LinkedIn profile
he had been with Bioware for two years
before bio we're working with 343
industries on halo 4 his linkedin page
also contains some possible hint at the
direction of Andromeda which he
described in his tweets as a game that
will blow people away to confirm what
some folks asked me about a few months
back I am no longer working on Mass
Effect Andromeda at Bioware Montreal
sincerely one of the best experiences of
my career I am incredibly grateful to
have worked with such talented and truly
wonderful human beings I think Mass
Effect Andromeda is really going to blow
people away couldn't be prouder to be
part of it and excited like a little kid
to play the final when it's out all that
said very happy to be back in Seattle
working with a scrappy little company
called Bungie that some of you may have
heard of think we might have some
interesting stories to tell one of his
duties included expansion of traditional
Bioware storytelling tools and
techniques into new areas leveraging
increased player choice and agency in
world narrative and and synchronous
storytelling at the end of 2015 another
high-ranking Andromeda developer senior
producer chris win left Bioware here
since joined the h1z1 developer daybreak
games so what do you think this means
for Andromeda is it heading for troubled
waters or are you confident that Bioware
can still create a great RPG let us know
in the comments section below or you can
find me on Twitter at a regular Dave and
for your mass effect news stay tuned to
gamespot com
you